okay let's go next to our caller from
the 773 area code who's calling today
from 773 hello yeah that's you
Oh oh my god
hey David hi my name is Barry I want to
apologize I've been wanting to become a
member for a while it seems like every
time I want to become a member
something crazy happens right but the
reason why I'm calling is because of the
election in Wisconsin yep so like I
write into the show like super tatts
often about stuff what's going on in
Wisconsin so I'm working on like a
campaign here and you know I've been
making around 200 250 calls a day Wow
the residents here trying to get them to
get absentee ballots ah and they
literally ran out of absentee ballots
they're sending people absentee ballots
late and then it's due on you know
Thursday but you know people aren't
going to be able to get it sent out and
they only are going to have 12 voting
locations in the Milwaukee area right
it's usually over a hundred I guess my
question is what effect do you think
that this is going to have on like the
rest of the election like the fact that
this election is still going to go on
yeah I so earlier this week we did a
story about how Nancy Pelosi is now
saying we really need to do vote-by-mail
and I fear that this this is going to
have a huge effect as my fear especially
because people staying home is is very
much partisan in the sense that
Republicans are much more likely to not
take the virus seriously and to just go
out in public so if we get to November
it is very likely that if there are
still virus fears and it seems like
that's certainly plausible it may even
be the start of the second wave at that
point in time we don't know my guess is
if it's not vote-by-mail you are going
to have way more people who would be
going out to vote for the Democratic
nominee
staying home versus trumpets who are
more likely to just say hey this is no
big deal I'm gonna go out and vote so I
believe we need to go to a full vote by
mail system all we're really we have the
infrastructure we're basically just
saying let's give an absentee ballot to
everyone instead of having to justify
why you get an absentee ballot yeah I
think also the last question I was
having like my girlfriend lost her job
no several co-workers that they had to
let go cuz we went from canvassing to
just a hundred percent phone baking and
so they don't need as many people right
uh and you know leases are coming you
know do that people have to decide when
they're gonna move yeah and like today
like this time is like the worst time
ever to try to find a new job yes
because I've been like looking for
different jobs for her and the
interviews you got to do interviews on
phone calls or Skype call and then you
have to get trained if they do hire you
remotely right yeah there are all sorts
of follow-on effects that we still don't
know the full scope of like as you're
pointing out on the first day of the
month leases are do mortgages or do a
lot of people aren't going to be able to
pay those that will then have a
subsequent effect and then you'll have
people needing jobs but it being a
terrible time to go and look for a job
and a lot of companies are not not not
only are they not hiring they're laying
people off what I come away with is the
stimulus probably needs to be bigger and
two-thirds of it shouldn't have gone to
corporations more should have gone to
people so we can give them more than
twelve hundred bucks yeah there's the
last thing I wanted to let you know that
my girlfriend was a very like non
political person and now I have her
watching your show almost every day love
it love it alright we'll say hi to her
for me okay
alright alright we'll talk to you later
great to hear from Barry in Wisconsin